championing mary thanks for being with
us how you doing
uh thank you for having me yeah good
good um flew straight out on holiday so
we're gonna get some rest over here
after a heavy couple of days
yeah well deserved rest as well but i'm
sure you'll see still keep the partying
going you're a champion now look just
talk us through how that felt winning
that trophy is a must felt like a long
tournament a tough tournament but you
played very well and you guys came away
with a win
thank you yeah i think the team was
fantastic um
i think obviously been working really
hard preparing um and it and it felt
like a a long time of preparing for
for such a short whirlwind um i honestly
i loved every minute of it um
and i'm so glad that we walked away with
gold
tell us about that preparation then
because obviously there's been a lot of
credit given to uh your manager serena
weigman um how does she prepare you guys
for something like this i mean she's a
she's a pro at it she won with the dutch
uh last time around and now she's done
it with you guys
yeah i mean she's obviously very very
good at what she does um
i i think her the biggest thing that she
she brought in was a real
um honesty and directness transparency
um but it also came with a lot of
calmness there was never
you know you never see her overly
emotional about things um which is
probably a little bit crazy as an
english person i think we're really
obviously passionate people um and i
think serena is passionate but in a
really controlled way um which
i think just helped keep the group quite
level um and really task focused um
so yeah brilliant i mean that's really
interesting isn't it because that is
kind of management style you're a united
player and obviously we know all about
hair dryer treatment that uh used to be
a management style for some so keeping
cool keeping calm it gives you guys the
confidence doesn't it just go out there
and do your job and do it to the best of
your ability
yeah i think that's like the most
important thing really is making sure
that we're staying focused on on the job
that we came to do because it's really
hard in a tournament when the games are
coming thicker thick and fast
um and you're just you know you're going
from like a matchday minus one train in
a match day -2 training and i think it's
really important that um
you stay super
super in it super present um and i think
that was really the focus and i was
really conscious personally um of
enjoying every second because it's been
a difficult couple of years and i think
to to be in it you just want to remember
every every single
feeling that you had in it i i kept
saying to my family like if i could
bottle this feeling oh my god it would
just be unreal i just want to drink from
that drink from that bottle of water
every day
can you describe what that feeling is
like i mean look you're playing the
biggest tournament of your life in your
home country the whole country is behind
you
and you're doing really well it's not
like you're failing you're doing really
well so like the pressure must be
building what is that like
i don't think i've ever experienced
anything like it really oh i've got some
good facials on those pictures i don't
know wow um
don't worry my hands on that ball it's
nice
that's all that matters i don't care i
don't care about your face as long as
the balls out the back of the net i'm
happy um
yeah i think you know what we work
really hard to try and keep the noise
out as much as possible uh which is
obviously quite difficult to do um with
with the fact that we were hosting the
tournament as well
um but we all made a lot of sacrifices
um i even left the family whatsapp group
made sure that we kept as much noise out
of it as possible no means nothing uh i
didn't you know i didn't want to see
anything i just wanted to be really in
it with the girls um because the girls
are great the group so talented
um and i knew that if we stayed focused
and true to our goal like i really
thought it was um a possibility that we
could come away with gold and then
that's exactly what we did
and talk to us a little bit about the
position you play uh
in my late years i've retired to being
in gold retired i've moved back to being
a goalkeeper you're tired to being in
golf no just the wrong way i mean
striker now i'm a goalkeeper anyway look
right there's a goalkeeper union isn't
there there's a way of playing it's a
lot of pressure as a keeper like i said
you had an excellent tournament made
some big stars but can you describe for
us what it's like being at wembley and
having to make saves like that in front
of all of those people because i get
scared down at the local goals trying to
make saves
i think the hardest part about
goalkeeping is that um
you are needed in moments and
it doesn't really matter how it happens
you've just got to make the save to keep
the team in the game and that sounds
really
um i don't know like a weird way to put
it but
it's the hardest thing to articulate how
hard goalkeeping is because there's no
right way everybody does it so
differently
um and i think
it is a very it is a very pressurized
position but but i absolutely love it i
wouldn't want to play any other position
and
it's just it's the best feeling when you
can help the team but of course like
those moments are big pressure moments
but that's that's what i've been
training for um and unfortunately this
this tournament it it came off and i was
i was able to help the team
yeah man you played really well as i
keep saying now i know you're from
nottingham you're actually from west
brookford i think which is where i grew
up as well so we've got a little
connection there now who was your
goalkeeper where's he massive in the
house
exactly
now who was your goalkeeping idol then
mark crossley
oh i don't know you know what
um i
i grew up watching loads of different
goalkeepers but probably mostly in in
the premier league and i like to try and
just i say i just watch so much
goalkeeping so much football that
i just tried to take not not tried to
take bits from every single one but i
try and take inspiration from every
single one because um there's no way i
can i can do all the things that they
can do but um i think it's just
important as a goalkeeper that you try
and develop your own style but
definitely had a lot of goalkeeping
inspiration going up you know whether
that's manuel neuer or buffon or to
stegan or um you know pepe rayner
um all these types of people joe heart
you could see us i could go on and on
and on i just used i just love football
so much and i watch it as much as
possible
and i love watching football and
goalkeeping at the highest level and
it's just so much fun to see
yeah absolutely right and you name some
great keepers then so look you say
you're on your holidays now are you
going to be watching football because
the premier league sites in a couple of
days doesn't it or are you going to take
a bit of a break from the game
yeah i would love to sit here and say
that i'm going to be football free
there's just absolutely no chance um
i'll definitely be putting the prom on
as soon as it's on um but for now i'm
going to go dive in the pool outside
because i am dying to get out in the sun
all right you crack on mary herbs
congratulations thank you so much for
talking to us um please pass on our
congratulations to the entire team and
uh good luck for the world cup which we
hope you will bring home as well
thank you very much great to talk to you
nice to talk to you thank you